when i got to say like dance with me and
all that
that really came from me seeing calvin
harris when he made
acceptable in the 80s and i was like i
like this
like who's this like who's this oh i
wanna i wonder if i could get a beat
from him and rap on his stuff
[Music]
for some reason when i call myself dizzy
i don't know where
dj dizzy when i was a jungle dj drummond
bass
and then um i went to school one day and
i was acting up
and the teacher said oh you're such a
raw school so i was like year eight
and i like the name rascal so i changed
my name to rascal but people are still
calling me dizzy
so i just put the two together i grew up
in bold east london
sometimes it was edgy sometimes it was a
little bit rough
but in other times it was like it was
amazing so many of my fondest memories
even up tonight's i'm 35 now
man i still
some of my best memories are still from
bowls so it's wicked one thing about
growing up on the council estate you
is you learn just community i feel like
there's more community in in
on a council estate than anywhere else
i've ever lived
but you said it was it was a bit rough
at times but what was what do you mean
by that
regular inner city problems drugs crime
crime rate just stuff like that you have
to navigate
as a youth sometimes you sometimes you
dabble you got involved
sometimes you just see it happening
around you when i was growing up in the
90s or whatever
so i guess around 92 i didn't understand
but there was a recession
in the 92 so it was just rough off the
off the
off the back of that anyway well i got
my passion for music involved like
i'd hear some of the older boys who had
like bedroom djs blaring out jungle from
their windows
and talk about in like the early 90s and
that that's that's like that's
that was like the soundtrack at the
looked time to most as a child honestly
probably my mum because i
was like like my mom raised me
by herself her effort her hustle her
like the way she worked so hard and then
did other stuff so many legal ways of
getting money
motivated me to not be lazy and go that
extra mile always my mom would go
to buy clothes from the wholesalers
bring them back to this eight and sell
them
then i picked it up and learned to do
that too i'm doing like we'll do
laboring where we have
a wake up would have boxes of envelopes
in the living room
you'd have to put the put the letters in
in the
envelopes and all that and that might be
a files in the box
you have some people like their parents
want to push them in a certain direction
i wanted to do music my mum made sure i
got
turntables they weren't the best
turntables my mom has made sure she
helped me get the turntables
there are some wears on my estate twins
and one of them was a really good mc
and he was like a really really good
friend of mine eventually if you're
watching them
mc sometimes i would touch mike and i
wanted to be an emcee so then i'll pick
up the mic
and then i learned to mc i learned to
rap people know me as graham or whatever
but i actually learned to
actually write rams on on drum and bass
tempo
a lot of people that i was emceeing with
around those times were just players
from whatever from my state or
not too far they might have been from
like newham like storming
who didn't introduce me to kano whatever
these are all people that were just kind
of
around they might have 20 minutes away
but it was local
you know it's like it was like a hobby
it's like trying to play football with
your friends or something that mattered
the most to me i thought about it all
the time wow
especially when i got into that making
tunes firstly i was really
i wanted to have the best lyrics and
want to be around the best mcs then when
i got to like
making beats and people liked him i just
couldn't wait to get my beats cut onto
that plate and then take him to the
radio
and hear other people emceeing on him
that was such a buzz for me
i'd already been putting out white
labels like white labels it's like
you've got a song
you go and press it press like 500 to go
and take it to the shop
the record shops at the time and then
you'd leave it with them and then you
come back and
everybody they sell they give you your
money it got so hot that eventually
i'd just go and take it to them they'd
give me the money straight up but then
eventually
got like a proper record deal and just
to hear my stuff on the radio and that
time last year was really underground
radio so it wasn't like i was going to
be hearing my stuff on mainstream radio
didn't care about mainstream radio about
that like i said it was just like a
sport that's what it felt like
so you have to understand from like the
first album we've covered like the
underground stuff so from the first
album
i kind of just powered through to the
third
sometimes i'll talk with other bigger
artists so
justin timberlake um red chili peppers
prodigy
or sean paul so i got to see other sides
of the of the game as i don't think by
the time i got to like the fourth album
part of me understood about kind of uh
making maybe an attempt up more
commercial stuff
and it's one of those things that it
went so well that people
assumed that i tried to go commercial
the record label tried to make me go
commercial
and that's when i started putting out
all that pop [ __ ] or whatever it didn't
happen like that that was like actually
one of the biggest
gambles in my life because if it would
have gone wrong it would have gone on
gone wrong it was on my own when i got
to
say like dance with me and all that if
i'm honest
that really came from me seeing calvin
harris on the tv
when he made acceptable in the 80s which
at the time
nothing sounded like that and i was like
i like this
like who's this like who's this i wanna
i wonder if i could get a beat from him
and rap on his stuff
and then i've ended up meeting him at a
music festival and telling him like you
know i like because
we should do something man and then
that's where i had my first
well first number one and that was huge
for me like we celebrated that that was
a big deal
that was a big deal to get number one
i've never rather number one before i
never had a number one album
and then whatever and then bonkers came
was sent to me i was in america the beat
was just sent to me
i just heard it and thought like okay
right this is like the stuff that i
hated when i was a kid that was on top
of the pop so
like like that kind of that that kind of
haas
kind of i wasn't really into that but i
had understood it because by now
i'd been to ibiza and understood what
that what that whole thing was as a kid
i didn't know
so that's why i was able to write
bonkers as well as what the subject
matter was based on me was having
nothing anxiety attack so that's what
i'm actually writing about but that's
what i understood about how to put a
song like that together
but even with that with that tune i
didn't
know it was going to be that big it
wasn't like uh right it's time to be a
pop star night it kind of came naturally
and there was no guarantees that it was
going to work because
not one of those records i just told you
about sounded like what was on the radio
at the time right now you think about it
it's like they were so big that it just
seemed like
obvious but at the time it wasn't like
that in a way sometimes it's easier
at the start even though you feel like
you've got everything to to prove you
you think less you just do more as you
go along
there's so much stuff that's not to do
with music that you end up getting
involved in and all that as well
and sometimes it's hard to get it's
harder to get inspiration in a way it's
been especially depending on how you
started
it's just hard to find inspiration to
just make new songs to make
people care on a mascara anyway think of
how many people make music on the planet
so for you to be one person that gets so
many people's attention especially in
the world we live now where everyone's
trying to get everyone's attention
they're like it's
crazy but then in the same way so
there's some things that are easier now
i've got a studio at home i can record
my own vocals
send them to an engineer send the beat
off have everything mixed and all that
and have
like a finished song pretty much what
what's the thing in your career you're
most proud of
my mom's sacrifice is worth it
definitely she got to see me
like do good and i'm going to do the
same with my little one so because
you you learn that
you know this [ __ ] ain't everything like
when i was a kid this [ __ ] was
everything to me
and then you learn like it's not
everything
it's just you learn to appreciate that
right like wow people take time out of
there
they to absorb my work
like and it means something to them when
i'm not here no more
i'm gonna have left so much like my
if i leave properly leave anything the
world
nature will deal with it eventually [ __ ]
will crumble empires crumble buildings
crumble whatever
but the music and whatever the influence
that will be left left behind what's
next for you
what's next for me um album of course so
i've finished my album it's called e3 f
that's what we're dealing with now man
it's going to be legendary it is it's
our it's our vibe from the beginning to
the end
i'm an originator so you know the signs
there
it's not regular sounds mate it's not
regular sounds it's gonna go off and
we've got some legends on there as well
but where do you see yourself being in
10 years
doing this doing what i'm doing now
i see myself doing this in another 30
years time probably i can't think of
nothing else i'd want to do
it's it's beyond like it's an obsession
like it's that this is just
what i do i've done this since i was a
kid like it's second nature to me
but looking back on it now a lot older
i just i think i feel like blessed that
i'm part of something like
unique that's gone down in history i'm
just like yeah it's kind of proud
i did start with my life
you